you may remember Chris Gardner from the
movie The Pursuit of Happyness starring
Will Smith
if so you already know the story he was
a single father he pulled himself out of
homelessness to become a millionaire
stockbroker but of course like any movie
based on a true story it is gonna have
some parts that only gloss over the
events of a person's life and in today's
by graphics we want to tell you the true
rags to riches story of Chris Gardner in
order to understand how Chris Gardner
found the strength to pull himself out
of poverty and go on to become a
millionaire you need to know the story
of how he was raised
his mother was Betty Jean Gardner and
she grew up in a very poor community in
the state of Louisiana in the 1940s
there are very few opportunities for
black people outside of working on a
farm
Betty wanted to get out of a small town
and move on to bigger and better things
she studied very hard and graduated
third in a high school class her goal
was to go to college and become a
full-time schoolteacher
unfortunately her parents could not
afford to pay a tuition that he got a
job as a substitute teacher at the local
school instead this is where she met the
man of her dreams
Samuel Salter he was handsome
college-educated and great with kids
the only problem it was already married
but he told her that he loved her and he
planned to leave his wife so that he
could marry her that he kept their
relationship a secret of course and when
she was 22 she got pregnant with Psaltis
child suddenly the situation became all
too real and he backed out on his
promise to leave his wife Betty's
parents they were ashamed and they
refused to help her keep the baby all of
Betty's brothers had already moved to
Milwaukee new factories were opening on
a regular basis and there were plenty of
blue-collar job opportunities therefore
she moved there to live with him she
gave birth to her daughter Ofili Erin's
again her life as a single mum but
unfortunately she didn't know that the
man she was about to fall in love with
would lead to heartbreak yet again she
had an affair with Thomas Turner who was
Chris's biological father and he also
refused to leave his wife to be with her
Chris was born in 1954 and Betty was
raising her two children alone she
finally decided it was time to date a
single man who would be devoted to her
so she married a man named
Fredi triplets who was very tall and
muscular in his autobiography Chris
Gardner
writes that Freddy was a frightening
looking giant and he cannot even fathom
why his mother chose to be with him he
was illiterate with only a third-grade
education he was also an alcoholic and
had a violent temper he would beat Betty
and he would beat the children as well
as pick up his shotgun and threatened to
shoot them Betty had previously been on
welfare but she took on two jobs in
order to earn enough money to leave
Freddy behind when he found out about
her plan he reported to social services
that she was working and should no
longer qualify for welfare however this
is a pretty serious crime because it's
welfare fraud the police state showed up
to arrest Betty and they didn't care
that she was pregnant with her daughter
Sharon she spent the next three years in
jail
Freddy refused to take care of Ophelia
and Chris so they grew up in a foster
home maybe Sharon was born in prison and
Freddy's mother agreed to Cather when
betty was eventually released she
regained custody of Chris and philia
unfortunately they bet he fell into the
cycle of abuse Freddy apologized and
promised to change so they got back
together but of course he continued to
beat her and the children bet he knew
that Freddy would never stop so she
burns down the house while he was asleep
inside it in an attempt to kill him
Chris would later say I can say honestly
I'm sorry she didn't succeed but Freddy
survived and Betty ended up going to
jail for a second time for the arson
Chris and his siblings grew up being
raised in various relatives houses
around Milwaukee most of his childhood
was spent playing unsupervised in the
streets he became the target of a child
predator and he was raped for some
people this would have been enough to
destroy them but Chris pushed down the
trauma and he tried to move forward
later in life he saw that same man again
and he picked up a nearby cinderblock
and smashed his rapists head in with it
and left in that bleed when Betty was
released from prison she made sure to
instill her love of Education into her
children she would take Chris to the
public library and she would tell him
that everything he would ever want to
know was contained within the walls of
the library this felt somewhat magical
to him and he excelled in school even
though all of Betty's dreams had been
crushed
she was never pessimistic and she
encouraged her own children to succeed
in his autobiography Chris Gardner
writes that there were two defining
moments that led to his success
when he was 16 years old he was watching
a March Madness NBA game and side saying
out loud to himself one day those guys
are gonna make a million dollars his
mother overheard him and said son if you
want to one day you can make a million
dollars for the first time in his life
he felt like he had permission to
succeed he had no idea how he would
become a millionaire but he knew that he
wanted to make it happen
[Music]
since his mother could not afford to
help him go to college Chris Gardner was
willing to go wherever he needed in
order to pull himself out of his poverty
he joined the Navy after high school and
spent four years serving as a medic he
with stations at a Marine Corps Base in
North Carolina during this time he met a
cardiac surgeon named dr. Robert Ellis
who offered him a medical research
position at the University of California
Medical Center in the Veterans Hospital
in San Francisco after two years he
became the manager of medical laboratory
and co-authored several research papers
with dr. Ellis on June the 18th 1977 he
married a woman named sherry Dyson she
was a maths teacher from Virginia when
they first got married Chris had plans
to spend the next ten years of his life
working in the lab while putting himself
through Medical School however the
medical field was beginning to change
and it was becoming more and more
expensive to enter the profession than
ever before he decided that he would
rather find a job that made money right
away instead of spending so many years
in school and then hoping to get a
payoff later sherry Dyson was
disappointed that Chris was giving up
his dream of becoming a doctor their
relationship was also falling apart and
he ultimately met and fell in love with
the dental students named Jackie Medina
only three months into their affair
Jackie became pregnant with that child
in 1980 Chris left his wife and he began
living with his girlfriend Jackie so
that they could raise their son together
throughout his childhood Chris's
stepfather Freddie triplet would always
tell him I ain't your daddy
I'm holding a shotgun to his head Chris
grew up wondering who his biological
father
actually was he swore to himself that
someday he would be the opposite of a
stepfather he wanted to become the best
father he could be and he would never
abandon or abuse his own child at first
they were a happy family and they were
optimistic about their future
but when Jackie graduated from dental
school she failed her board exams which
and that she could not work as a dentist
she was forced to give up her dreams and
become a stay-at-home mum there ends in
San Francisco it was too expensive for
Jackie and Chris to pay on a single
income so they had to move outside of
the city the research position at the
hospice always only paid $7,500 a year
which was hardly enough to support
Jackie and his son he found a higher
paying job selling medical supplies to
doctors in the Bay Area
he was now making twenty five thousand
dollars a year and men who were higher
up in the same industry made about
$80,000 a year to put that in
perspective with modern inflation this
was like leaving a 23
and dollar per year salary for a
seventy-six thousand dollar per year job
with the potential to make two hundred
and forty four thousand dollars Chris
Gardner had everything going for him and
his dream of becoming a millionaire it
seemed ever closer but this all changed
when he was 26 years old Chris was
leaving his job and was in the parking
lot of the hospital a man driving a red
Ferrari was circling the parking lot and
looking for a spot he wore a suit to tie
a watch and he clearly looked incredibly
successful Chris waved the man down and
said that he could have his parking
space in exchange for information
he asked what do you do and how do you
do it the man told him that he was a
stockbroker and they agreed to meet for
coffee the next day he learned that the
man's name was Bob bridges and he gave
Chris the rundown on the very basics of
the stock market this man was making
$80,000 a month and that's all Chris
needed to hear he decided that his new
dream was to become a stockbroker but
even back then most trading firms
required at minimum an MBA before they
would even consider hiring a rookie
stockbroker did he continue to spend
more and more time essentially
apprentice at Bob bridges firm you see
most of the skills needed in the stock
market their lands on the job and not in
school so Chris was learning how it
could be possible for him to make a
tremendous amount of money if only he
was given the opportunity to work for a
firm but bridges helped him secure
interviews with various investment firms
that offered training programs but they
kept saying no to make that as worse he
racked up parking tickets every time he
went on an interview now this might
sound like a trivial detail right now
but those parking tickets they came back
to bite him in a big way years later
Chris Gardner was asked if he thought
racism had anything to do with the fact
that it was so difficult to land a
rookie position he said absolutely not
think about it I had never gone to
college he's gonna do business with you
that's places 'im it could have thanked
anybody in this room but I kept coming
back Jackie wasn't convinced from her
perspective chris was skipping out on
sales calls to chase after a pipe dream
she called him delusional and was
frustrated and angry that he was
neglecting his real job in her defense
she had very good reasons to be concerns
and she already knew from her failure
what it was like to work hard towards
something for years only to have it fall
apart in the end despite the fact that
she did not believe in him Chris
continued to learn and he interviewed at
as many
see Kurt after an entire year he was
offered a chance to join an unpaid
internship positions become an
entry-level trainee there was no
guarantee that he would even get the
trainee job if he did he would be taking
a huge pay cut compared to what he made
as a medical supply salesman the one
major difference was of course that as a
stockbroker there is no ceiling on how
much money you can make and Chris wants
to be a millionaire
finally after trying and failing for
over a year Kristin got accepted into
the training program of a firm called EF
Hutton he quit his job as a medical
supply salesman because he was confident
that things were only going to go up
from there tragically though just a week
later when he showed up for the first
day of the job there was a new hiring
manager working at EF Hutton they looked
at his resume and they retracted the job
offer just like that in an instant
Chris's life began to crumble you have
to go home to tell Jackie that he quit
his sales job and he wasn't going to
work for you Hutton either she was upset
but he tried his best to make ends meet
he began to guess odd jobs like cutting
lawns and continued to work towards
becoming a stockbroker but he and Jackie
they began to get into a lot more
arguments one day during a particularly
bad fight that neighbors called the
police because they believed that it may
escalate into domestic violence when the
police officer checked his record he saw
that garden had racked up $1,200 in
unpaid parking tickets he did not have
the ability to pay them so he was taken
to jail and held for 10 days during
those 10 days all he could think about
was his son he didn't want his little
boy to believe that his father had left
him he was scheduled to show up for
another job interview on the 9th day 24
hours before he was set to be released
he figured that he would never make it
and that would be the end of his dream
but he asked the police officer if he
could make a phone call to reschedule
the appointment technically he was not
allowed to make a second phone call but
the officer broke the rules and let him
do it
he made stators of this nothing will
ever convince me that it was anything
other than the hand of God
Chris was released from prison the next
morning at 6 a.m. and he rushed home to
his apartment to take a shower and get a
suit on before the interview by the time
he got there
Jackie had cleared out the apartments
and the bank accounts she had taken
everything but the dust most importantly
she had taken my little boy he was
forced to show up at his interview at
Dean Witter Reynolds wearing the same
clothes that he had been arrested in 10
days earlier miraculously he got
accepted into the training program
[Music]
when Jackie left him she also took all
of the money that they'd been saving for
rent so Chris he was kicked out of his
apartment he continued learning very
small amounts of money from cutting
grass and painting which was enough to
pay for a single room in a boarding
house he began going to his training
program during the day to take classes
and only coming back to the tiny room to
go to sleep just three months after
leaving him Jackie returned to find
Chris she realized that she didn't want
to be a single mother and she wanted to
try and rebuild her medical career so
she asked Chris to take their son he
gladly took Chris jr. back and agreed to
take sole custody of him while Jackie
moved on with her life and never looked
back however the boarding house it did
not allow children and they forced them
to leave many of the men's homeless
shelters they wouldn't accept children
either or they would fill up too quickly
before he was able to receive any food
or shelter Chris never panhandled and he
tried his best to hide the fact that he
was homeless he always wore a suit and
pushed his son around in the stroller to
most people Park on the street they
would assume he was just another father
going somewhere however the local sex
workers they took notice - Chris walking
through the ghetto the same time every
night and figures what was going on
these ladies of the night they would
slip five-dollar bills - stodla Chris
jr. their kindness together with his
work mowing lawns on the weekends was
just enough money to help them survive
even then though they barely held on by
a threat gunner said it was a choice to
eat or stay on a hotel we chose to eat
Chris was always on the move and they
would find places to sleep wherever they
could sometimes friends would let them
sleep on their couch other times when he
works late into the night at the firm he
and his son would hide under his desk to
sleep in the office when there was no
other option
Chris would lock him in a subway station
bathroom they were able to clean
themselves in the bathroom sink and lay
down on the floor to sleep when he
closed desires he still dared to dream
of wearing a new suit and driving a red
Ferrari in one of his darkest moments
Chris was feeling completely overwhelmed
since has an incredible amount of
self-doubt he had to give a son a bath
by candlelight because there was no
electricity where they were staying
just when he felt ready to give up his
son said you know what
you're a good Papa this was enough to
keep him going Chris began going to
church to listen to a man named Reverend
Cecil Williams become Sunday mornings
Chris was standing in Food lines
and the reverence couldn't help but
notice him because there were countless
homeless single mothers but he was the
only single father sessile Williams had
a program for these mothers at the
glider Memorial Methodist Church once
Chris found out about the program he
asked the Reverend if he could make an
exception and let them in so he did
finally Chris Garner and his son they
had a place where they knew they were
guaranteed to have a roof over their
head
[Music]
after this year-long unpaid internship
Chris Gardner passed his series 7 exam
and officially became a stockbroker he
got a job at the San Francisco based
firm Bear Stearns and company he was
finally paid a base salary of $1,000 a
month which is two thousand three
hundred and fifty four dollars after
modern inflation it was enough for Chris
to start renting a studio apartment for
himself and his son and with that they
were no longer homeless but of course it
didn't stop there
now that he finally had his opportunity
to work in that field Chris Gardner
completely devoted his life to becoming
the best stockbroker he could possibly
be he showed up early
he stayed late and worked ten times
harder than anyone else in 1987 he began
another nearly impossible dream by
starting his own firm called Gardner
rich and Coe with just ten thousand
dollars of his own money through hard
work and persistence he was able to
gather up clients until his firm was
incredibly successful today he has an
estimated net worth of 60 million
dollars and yes eventually he did buy a
Ferrari but this wasn't just any Ferrari
this was a Testarossa that belonged to
Michael Jordan Gardner changed the
license plate to say not MJ Chris
Gardner wrote his autobiography called
the pursuit of happiness and it became a
best-seller in 2006 a movie version of
his life was made starring Will Smith
after the movie was complete Smith and
his wife were so moved by the story that
they decided to donate $75,000 to the
homeless shelter run by Reverend Cecil
Williams Chris Gardner continues to
volunteer at the soup kitchen as well as
give financial donations after the
premiere of the movie in 2006 the United
States entered the financial crisis just
two years later for years there was this
stigma that people only became homeless
if they were mentally ill or drug
addicts but the recession taught us that
in a time of crisis it can truly happen
to anyone even if they did everything
right in their lives the movie of Chris
Gardner's life it began to resonate with
people years beyond the movie's initial
release and he has been invited to speak
to help inspire people at countless
public events in 2010 Chris Gardner said
during a speech we have in fact seen the
creation of a whole new class of
homeless something I call white collar
homeless when two school played by the
rules colored within the lines than the
world changes just like that if we learn
anything from the story of Chris Gardner
it's that bad luck could make things in
Our Lives completely fall apart
maybe we
won't hit absolute rock bottom but life
happens whether we're ready for it or
not and no matter how many times we
fumbled it's still possible to pull
ourselves back up and keep going towards
our dreams no matter how crazy they
might seem so I really hope you enjoyed
that video hope found it inspiring if
you haven't seen the pursuit of
happiness
highly recommended definitely check that
out or check out some of my other videos
you'll find those linked to on the
screen now and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]